president Trump moves to stop his former
White House Counsel from testifying a
court rules against Trump on his
financial records and Tim Cook laments
how baby boomers betrayed Millennials
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show well we have a lot to get to today
I promise no Thrones talk no game of
Thrones talk we did all of it yesterday
so if you want to hear that stuff listen
to yesterday's show not today's show
well that's all the actual news today
but first rings mission is to make
neighborhoods safer you might already
know about their smart video doorbells
and cameras that protect millions of
people everywhere ring helps you stay
connected to your home anywhere in the
world so if there's a package delivery
or a surprise visitor you'll get an
alert you'll be able to see hear and
speak to them all from your phone that
is thanks to HD video and two-way audio
features on marine devices I am obsessed
with personal security considering all
the threats I get and that's why I trust
ring when I'm out of town I know who's
at my door as a listener you have a
special offer on a ring starter kit
available right now with a video
doorbell and motion activated floodlight
cam the starter kit has everything you
need to start building a ring of
security around your home just go to
ring.com slash bend that is ring comm /
BAM the thing that you owe to your
family more than anything else is to
make sure that your home is safe ring
comm / Ben can help you make that happen
it's ring.com
/ Ben get that ring of security started
honestly the world is we live thank God
in pretty safe country but the world is
becoming less safe in a lot of ways ring
calm / Ben ensures that your home stays
safe
go get a special deal when you go over
to ring calm / Ben go check them out
right now ring calm / Ben use that / Ben
to let them know that we sell you all
righty so the big news of the day is
that President Trump is now being
subjected to new scrutiny so according
to a court president Trump must now
allow his accountants to turn over his
financial records according to a lower
court judge this from the New York Times
president Trump's accounting firm must
turn over his financial records to
Congress a federal district court ruled
on Monday rejecting his legal team's
argument that lawmakers had no
legitimate power to subpoena the files
Trump vowed that his legal team would
appeal rather than permit the firm
Meszaros USA to comply with the subpoena
and the ruling so the legal fight is far
from over the ruling by the judge whose
name is a meet Metta over the US
District Court for the District of
Columbia was an early judicial test of
the president vowed to systemic
systematically Stonewall all subpoenas
by House Democrats stymieing their
ability to perform
oversight of mr. Trump and the executive
branch after what in control of the
chamber in last year's midterm elections
mr. Trump's legal team led by William s
con Savoy had argued that the House
Committee on Oversight and reform had no
legitimate legislative purpose in
seeking Trump's financial records and
was just trying to dig up dirt like
finding out whether the president broke
any waters for political reasons
so the subpoena exceeded its
constitutional authority Democrats claim
they need the records because they're
examining whether foreigners are in a
position to use business dealings with
the President to exert hidden influence
over American policymaking and whether
ethics and disclosure laws need to be
strengthened judge Mehta is an Obama
appointee of course he said that the
justification was sufficient to make the
subpoena valid he said these are
facially valid legislative purposes it
is not for the courts to question
whether the committee's actions are
truly motivated by political
considerations accordingly the court
will enter judgment in favor of the
Oversight Committee now this ruling is
fairly absurd it's fairly absurd
it relies extremely heavily on a 1957
court ruling that talked about how
private citizens could not be targeted
by the federal government by Congress
but made a distinction for government
figures and quote-unquote legitimate
government purposes the question is is
there a line that is supposed to be
drawn when it comes to how far Congress
can go in seeking information on
somebody who holds elected office this
case seems to suggest no this case seems
to suggest that Congress can for any
reason as long as they can just say
investigation Congress can for any
reason at all grab information on
basically any elected official that's
that's a pretty wide and broad ruling by
Mehta there's a 1957 Supreme Court
decision as I mentioned hot air points
this out the limited congressional
authority for investigations when it
comes to private individuals this judge
took care to rule that his decision fits
well within that precedent noting that
presidents are not private individuals
and that the private behavior before and
during their tenure in office can be
grounds for impeachment Mehta notes that
Congress went unchallenged in its
authority to open such investigations
into prior administrations he wrote
quote twice in the last 50 years
Congress has investigated a sitting
president for alleged law violations
before initiating impeachment
proceedings it did so in
1873 by establishing the Senate Select
Committee on presidential campaign
activities better known as the Watergate
committee and then did so again in 1995
by establishing the special committee to
investigate whitewater Development
Corporation and related matters now
whitewater obviously happened before
Clinton was president
although Watergate happened while
Clinton while Nixon was president the
former investigation included within its
scope potential corruption by Nixon
while in office
the latter concerned alleged legal
misconduct by President Clinton before
his time in office Congress plainly
views itself as having sweeping
authority to investigate illegal conduct
of a president before and after taking
office this Court is not prepared to
roll back the tide of history well as
hot air points out the Supreme Court
wasn't asked in any of these cases
whether the Whitewater investigation
exceeded Congress's Authority also we
already knew about whitewater I mean
there there were already public reports
about corruption in whitewater and at
this point there's no information that
suggests that President Trump is
actually subject to some sort of
nefarious criminal foreign activity with
regard to being leveraged because of his
finances Trump has called the ruling
crazy
he said we think it's totally the wrong
decision by obviously an Obama appointed
judge Trump's attorneys have already
appealed this thing and again I think
that there is a solid case that Trump
can make that Congress has to have some
limitations here I mean it is truly
astonishing that a court is ruling that
basically any time Congress wants to dig
up any information about somebody who
holds elected office for any purpose
without presumably any actual hook for
the for the investigation that they are
allowed to do so that's it that's a
pretty amazing statement and it's
obvious that this this ruling is
politically driven I mean the ruling
opens with a quote from James Buchanan
you can tell what the judge thinks of
President Trump when he opens the ruling
with a quotation from James Buchanan and
widely derided as the worst presidents
in the history of the United States
the ruling itself says either the quote
from Buchanan is I solemnly protest
against these proceedings of the House
of Representatives because they're in
violation of the rights of the
coordinate executive branch for the
government and subversive of its
constitutional independence and then the
judge says these words written by
President James Buchanan in March 1860s
tat a resolution at
opted by the US House of Representatives
to form a committee known as the kavod
committee to investigate whether the
President or any other officer of the
executive branch had sought to influence
the action of Congress by improper means
you can ensure fully admitted that the
House of Representatives had the
authority to make inquiries incident to
their legislative duties as necessary to
enable them to discover and provide
appropriate legislative remedies but he
objected to the committee's
investigation of his conduct he
maintained that the House of
Representatives possessed no general
powers to investigate him except when
sitting as an impeaching body you cannon
feared that if the house were to
exercise such authority it would
establish a precedent too dangerous and
embarrassing to all my successors so
whatever political party they might be
attached some 160 years later President
Trump has taken up the fight of his
predecessor again this is a judge was
politically motivated if he's quoting
Buchanan there are plenty of presidents
who have argued that Congress does not
have this sort of investigative
authority including President Clinton
but he's not citing President Clinton or
say Barack Obama who used executive
privilege in order to shield documents
from Congress's prying eyes in the Fast
and Furious scandal this judge is
deliberately trying to humiliate Trump
by quoting James Buchanan and by the way
just because Buchanan made the argument
doesn't mean that the argument is
actually constitutionally wrong
Buchanan's argument he may be a crappy
president but his argument which is that
Congress only gets to use its
investigative powers in the context of
an impeachment proceeding that they
can't in other words just say you know
what I'm now subpoena every tax record
from every accountant of every
politician on the other side because we
theoretically have the power to impeach
anybody look where does this stop let's
say that you are the Democratic the
Democrats in the house and let's say you
just don't like Ted Cruz or you just
don't like Mitch McConnell can they now
subpoena all financial records from
Mitch McConnell he holds elected office
the same way that Donald Trump holds
elected office presumably without any
reference points they could just issue
subpoenas to the accountants for Mitch
McConnell suggesting that maybe he's
been compromised by foreign authorities
and according to this judge McConnell's
accountants would then have to turn over
all of that material I mean if the idea
is that if you are a public official
you're now exposed to scrutiny without
any sort of any sort of hook any sort of
actual crime that you think has been
committed you're just speculating as to
whether a crime could have been
committed this is gonna get very
dangerous very quickly and Democrats
have better pay attention to this
because if Republicans retake the
Congress and let's say there's a
Democrat who's president and Republicans
decide you know what we're gonna do
exactly what Democrats did we're gonna
subpoena everything all the things like
where exactly does this stop what you
think Democrats would've been okay if
let's say that let's say the Congress
under the Republicans had said you know
we are afraid that Barack Obama
committed some sort of fraud in his
application to Occidental College that
maybe he committed a fraud like he had
claimed maybe he claimed that he was
foreign-born or something and all this
is speculative in nonsense but let's say
that they had said that and so they'd
subpoenaed Occidental College for his
admission records and Obama said wait a
second this has nothing to do with my
presidency you don't have any evidence I
committed a crime and Republicans were
like doesn't matter
we've got investigative power we can
investigate anything you're an elected
official what this is going to do is
create a situation where no one of any
level of decency runs for public office
ever again because no one is pure as the
driven snow and no one wants their life
turned over this way unless they are
absolutely shameless I mean there have
to be some limitations to this sort of
power but according to this judge there
are no limitations of this sort of power
the court says echoing the protests of
President Buchanan President Trump and
his associated entities are before this
court claiming that the oversight
committees subpoena to moszer's the the
accounting firm exceeds the committee's
constitutional power to conduct
investigation the president argues there
is no legislative purpose for the
subpoena the oversight committees true
motive the president insists is to
collect personal information about him
solely for political advantage he asks
the court to declare the nazzer subpoena
invalid and unenforceable courts have
grappled for more than a century says
the judge with the question of the scope
of Congress's investigative power the
binding principle that emerges from
these judicial decisions is that courts
must presume that Congress is acting in
furtherance of its constitutional
responsibility to legislate and must
defer to congressional judgments about
what Congress needs to carry out that
purpose to be sure there are our limits
on Congress's investigative Authority
but those limits do not substantially
constrain Congress what are those two
sentences even mean in in in context of
one another what are those sentences
mean there are limits on Congress's
investigative authorities but those
do not substantially constrain Congress
so in other word I mean that's like me
saying to my son who's screaming and
trying to stick a fork into an electric
socket you know there are limits on what
I'm gonna allow you to do but those
limits don't substantially constrain you
according to this judge so long as
Congress investigates on a subject
matter on which legislation could be had
Congress act as contemplated by article
1 of the Constitution well this is
denying the fact that the executive
branch also has separate powers but the
executive branch does not have to
subjugate itself to the legislative
power and more than that this does put
private citizens in danger because for
example let's say you're now a candidate
for public office or let's say that you
donated it to a candidate for public
office and Congress is now investigating
you
Congress unfortunately has got its thumb
in a bunch of areas in American life
that are purely private in scope
remember Congress used to have hearings
on congressional steroids in baseball
I mean if Congress has the power to do
this sort of investigative work like any
time they don't like somebody that can
dig up anything they want on them so
long as they can make the argument that
they're a public figure I don't know how
far this goes now maybe you say this
only applies to elected officials even
there how far are we going to take this
exactly can they subpoena president
Trump's phone records from The Times in
the 90s when he was when he was calling
up the New York Post as his own press
secretary hey how far can they go we'll
get some more of this in just a second
but first when the founders crafted the
Constitution you know a little thing
that we like to protect our rights the
first thing they did was to make sacred
the rights of the individual to share
ideas without limitation by their
government the second right day
enumerated was the right of the
population to protect that speech and
their own persons with force you know
how strongly I believe in these
principles I'm a gun owner owning a
rifle is an awesome responsibility and
building rifles is no different
started in a garage by marine vet more
than two decades ago Bravo Company
manufacturing BCM for short builds a
professional-grade product which is
built to combat standards this is
because BCM believes the same level of
protection should be provided to every
American regardless if they're a private
citizen or a professional Bravo Company
manufacturing is not a sporting arms
company the design engineer and
manufacture life-saving equipment the
people at BCM feel it is their moral
responsibility as Americans to provide
tools that will not fail the end user
when it's not just a paper
get someone coming to do them harm to
learn more about Bravo company
manufacturing head on over to Bravo
Company MFG comm where you can discover
more about their products special offers
and upcoming news that's Bravo Company
and FG comm you need more convincing
find out even more about PCM and the
awesome people who make their products
at youtube.com slash bravo company USA I
know the founders of this company they
are awesome folks go check them out
right now at bravo company MFG calm or
youtube.com / Bravo company USA
so this judge rules that applying these
principles compels the conclusion that
President Trump cannot block the
subpoena to his accountants according to
the Oversight Committee it believes that
the requested records will eat its
consideration of strengthening ethics
and disclosure laws as well as amending
the penalties for violating such laws
okay so this is an amazing claim by the
Oversight Committee they're not even
arguing at this point that President
Trump has committed a crime they are
arguing that in order for them to do
research on the possibility of
strengthening ethics and disclosure laws
generally not with application to trump
and amending the penalties for violating
such acts they now need access to the
president's personal finances I mean
that's an amazing statement so in other
words if I want to pass a piece of
legislation on any topic all I have to
do is say listen you know I'm doing
research to go back to the Barack Obama
college records example I'm doing
research on college loans and college
admissions and we're thinking of passing
some legislations on loans and
admissions in order for me to get some
background info on that I'm gonna need
Barack Obama's personal college records
wouldn't everybody go wait a second that
is not within Congress's scope but here
that's exactly what they're saying and
the judge is like no problem okay so get
some more of this in just one second the
judge goes even further than that
the judge says that according to this
Oversight Committee the records will
assist in monitoring the president's
compliance with the foreign emoluments
clause
these are facially valid legislative
purposes it is not for this courts a
question whether the committee's actions
are truly motivated by political
considerations accordingly the court
will enter judgment in favor of the
Oversight Committee well actually it is
for the court to question whether the
committee's actions are motivated by
political considerations if they cannot
name a in a relevant crook on which to
build this particular subpoena it's this
this
is so insanely broad and again Democrats
should understand that because this
could come back to bite them in a very
serious way a Republican will not be
President forever and Congress will not
be democratic forever
president Trump is correct to point out
that this ruling is kind of crazy
nonetheless it just exposes once again
that the judiciary is out of control
unfortunately and the I mean this is a
judiciary that is ruling consistently
that President Barack Obama had
authority to issue effectively immunity
for dreamers but but Donald Trump has no
executive authority to roll back the
immunity for dreamers the courts are out
of control
it's funny when the founders created the
Constitution what they hoped for was the
system of checks and balances now that
did not mean that all of the branches
were going to be equally powerful they
thought that the article one branch
legislature was going to be the most
powerful followed by the presidency
followed by the judiciary in many ways
what has happened is that the
legislature has become almost a
vestigial organ of government where all
legislation and regulation is actually
done from the executive branch except
when there's a political break between
Congress and the president in which case
the legislative branch acts as
effectively an investigative unit aided
by the judiciary this is a different
system of checks and balances than was
sought by the founders in the first
place the founders were hoping that the
lead check on the executive branch would
in fact lie in the legislative branch
but not really through impeachment so
much as controlling the means and
mechanisms of policy instead Congress
kicked all the means and mechanisms of
policymaking
over to the executive branch the
regulatory agencies do virtually all the
policy-making in American government now
and then when people in Congress don't
like the president instead of them
scaling back his authority to do things
they launch personal investigations into
his accounting practices from 1992 that
is not the sort of checks and balances
we were talking about and then you've
got the judiciary which steps in every
so often and quashes the ability of the
executive branch to enforce laws that
are duly on the books so it's very weird
there is a system of checks and balances
in place but the system of checks and
balances is completely different than
the system of checks and balances
originally envisioned by the founders
the founders thought that that the
legislative branch would zealous
guard its powers of rulemaking and
legislation they did not they handed
those to the executive they thought they
did the executive branch would zealously
guard its own powers against the
legislative authorities encroachment and
that has happened to a certain extent
but then the judiciary has overruled
that and created this weird new system
where the executive is basically in is
is effectively in by instituted with all
of these imbued imbued with all of these
powers and the only check on the powers
of the executive is investigations and
impeachment which is why which is why
our policymaking is so fractured right
now imagine if we went through the
normal channels for banking legislation
legislation started in the house and
then passed the Senate and the President
signed it rulemaking was not made by the
executive authority well that would
require all of these branches to work
together more than they do the system
that we have now is basically Congress
delegates all of its authority to the
executive and then whines about it when
the executive does what they don't want
them to do it's pretty amazing meanwhile
this sort of stupid system of checks and
balances continues to play out with
regard to don McGann president Trump is
now directed his former White House
Counsel time again to skip a House
Judiciary Committee hearing scheduled
for Tuesday citing a Justice Department
opinion that he cannot be compelled to
testify about his official duties McGann
confirmed on Monday evening that he
won't appear now this is not an argument
that McGann that McGann couldn't testify
if he wanted to if McGann wants to
testify he can the argument the
president Trump is making is that if
McGann does not testify there's no
punishment in store for him which is
actually true the development prompted
an obstinate response late on Monday
from House Judiciary Committee Chairman
Jerry Nadler of New York he said we're
having the hearing tomorrow we are
expecting mr. McGann to show up pursuant
to the subpoena they had the hearing
today there was no there was no McGann
showing up House Democrats are now
claiming that maybe they will push
forward with impeachment they have power
to do so are they actually going to do
it I have my serious doubts senator
Kirsten Gillibrand desperately
attempting to garner attention in this
presidential race while writing and a
high of zero percent in the polls says
well you know maybe this is going to
prompt impeachment of President Trump
that he doesn't allow his White House
Counsel former White House Counsel to
show up even after allowing his former
White House Counsel to testify to the
FBI which by the way if you
to the FBI that's a crime he would go to
jail but according to Gillibrand if he
doesn't show up and answer questions
from Democrats then obviously Trump is
going to be impeach yeah sure I think
what the Trump investigators of what the
Trump administration is doing is
fundamentally blocking our
constitutional right for oversight and
accountability over his administration
and they're doing it aggressively
certainly ignoring the contempt
proceedings against Barr is a step
telling witnesses like McGann that they
are not supposed to testify you know I
think it's something that speaker Pelosi
he has six Committees of jurisdiction
now they're trying to do oversight
investigations and I think she will
continue to push very hard to get
testimony and documents but if the
president keeps stonewalling it may
actually force the houses hands and they
might decide to start a future
proceedings because they need to get
access to the truth okay they have
access to the truth it was all in the
Milan report the house is basically just
frustrated they didn't get what they
wanted from the Mullen report and so now
they are making excuses they're digging
through president Trump's personal
finances and subpoena hang his
accountants and they're going after Tom
McGann who again testified in front of
robert muller and they're going after
William bard the Attorney General for
abiding by the law well get to attorney
generals Attorney General bars response
to all of this in just one second first
with stress and anxiety many people can
often feel exhausted during the day and
then it's time to go to bed you can't
fall asleep this happened to me all the
time okay I lead a fairly stressful if
thing in the public eye is not exactly
stress-free and you know a couple of
weeks ago we had some death threats on
us the FBI arrested somebody so sleep
was a little bit rough during that
period and that's where calm came in
calm calm if worry is affecting your
days and nights it's probably also
affecting your overall health and that's
why we have partnered with calm it's the
number one app to help you reduce your
anxiety and stress and help you sleep
better which is a big problem for me
that's why I need calm more than 40
million people around the world have
downloaded it if you head over to calm
calm / Ben you'll get 25% off a calm
premium subscription that includes
guided meditations on issues like
anxiety stress and focus including a
brand new meditation each day they're
also the Sleep stores is this stuff that
I love their bedtime stories for adults
designed to help you relax and you're
having trouble falling asleep well
listen to Stephen Fry read to you about
the match
lavender fields of southern France or
listen to Leona Lewis talk about the
moonlit jungles of Africa you are out
like a light man they even have soothing
music and more right now Ben Shapiro
listeners get 25% off a call him a
Premium Subscription
and comb comm slash pen that is ca LM
comm slash man can unlimited access to
all of coms content today at comb comm
so I spend works on kids by the way to
get comb and stop stressing comb calm
slash men okay so as I say the Attorney
General William bar is coming under fire
from Democrats as well they suggest that
they might impeach William Bar because
William bar has not handed them all of
the unredacted material that he is not
allowed to actually hand them so William
bar is responding according to The Wall
Street Journal bar has come under
criticism from Democrats and some
Republicans who say he is acting more
like the president's personal lawyer
than the nation's top law enforcement
officer the only Republican I've heard
who said that is Justin Amash the
Republican Congress person from Michigan
bar was a private citizen bristled at
the barrage of legal and other
challenges Trump faced during his first
two years in office said his long-held
belief in executive power is more about
protecting the presidency than the
current office holder he said I felt the
rules were being changed to hurt Trump I
thought it was damaging for the
presidency over the long haul when you
look at that court ruling that basically
says that Congress can subpoena anything
from any public official at any time for
any reason it's hard to disagree with
that sentiment apparently according to
The Wall Street Journal that sentiment
plus coaxing from friends led the 68
year old grandfather of five to sign on
for another turn at the helm of the
Justice Department where his quest to
protect presidential power has taken on
new significance in light of special
counsel Robert Muller's report and the
Trump administration's efforts to thwart
congressional oversight he said in an
interview at every grave juncture the
presidency has done what it is supposed
to do which is provide leadership and
direction if you destroy the presidency
and make it an errand boy for Congress
we're gonna be much weaker and a more
divided nation bar has jump to the front
lines of this Republican presidents
battle against Congress in the courts a
House committee has already voted to
hold Barr in contempt for providing them
the entire Mullah report as well as
access to the unredacted portions for
democrats who refuse to go look at it
many current and former law enforcement
officials according to The Wall Street
Journal have come to view mr. Barr
skeptically citing his newly launched
review of the investigations origins and
what he termed spying on Trump campaign
assaut
it's over ties to Russia he hasn't
explained specifically what prompted his
concerns giving fodder for mr. trump and
his allies to attack the department that
he leads Republicans have embraced bars
willingness to bring attentions to their
grievances with federal law enforcement
of course Trump is very happy with bar
because bar is defending him and
executive power at this point he said he
apparently spoke with the Wall Street
Journal last week and he suggested that
he is really not interested in
protecting Trump personally he just
believes that the rules are being
arbitrarily changed in order to harm
President Trump and again it is hard to
argue with that perspective given the
fact that Democrats were very much in
favor of Barack Obama using executive
privilege to shield Eric Holder had no
problem when Eric Holder called himself
the wingman for Barack Obama they were
very upset with with the Kenneth Starr
investigation which was predicated on
solid legal grounds I mean Bill Clinton
did commit perjury
he committed a series of crimes
including actual obstruction of justice
the Kenneth Starr probe was actually
into illegality no illegality has been
found about President Trump thus far
none you may say that he has done stuff
you don't like that's fine he's done
stuff I don't like either you may say
that the President of the United States
has done untoward things that is true
has he committed a criminal act even
robert muller who had full authority to
say so could not bring himself to say
that the president had done something
criminal here and yet we are seeing the
democrats expand the power of subpoenas
to include virtually everything in the
world
this seems like dangerous stuff to me
meanwhile Michael Cohen is out there
still making trouble for the president
Michael Cohen president Trump's former
longtime personal attorney President
Trump did not hire the best people as he
himself has admitted with regard to
Michael Cohen
apparently Michael Cohen told the House
panel during closed-door hearings
earlier this year he had been encouraged
by Trump's lure Jay Sekulow to falsely
claim in the 2017 statement to Congress
the negotiations to build the Trump
Tower in Moscow ended in January 2016
in fact Cohn later admitted that
discussions on the Moscow Tower
continued into June of the presidential
election year House Democrats are now
scrutinizing whether Sekulow or other
Trump attorneys played a role in shaping
Cohen's 2017 testimony to Congress
Cohen said he made the false statement
to help hide the fact that Trump had
potentially hundreds of millions of
dollars at stake
in a possible Russian project while he
was running for president Adam Schiff
who has made mountains out of molehills
for several years here he says we're
trying to find out whether anyone
participated in the false testimony that
Cohen gave to this committee well here's
the problem with this story the headline
says that Cohen told lawmakers that
seculow encouraged him to falsely to
falsely basically commit perjury before
Congress and yet Schiff is now saying
we're trying to find out whether this
happened well if Cohen said that it
happened
wouldn't they now have the grounds to
open some sort of criminal investigation
into seculow and the White House but
they don't and then they haven't been
able to come up with anything that's far
so it's just more Michael Cohen talk
doesn't matter press is gonna run with
it this is on the front page of The
Washington Post today so you know again
I think that these investigations into
president Trump are really designed to
do one thing and one thing only and that
is to exacerbate the feeling of chaos
that Trump naturally creates around him
President Trump has a strong reelect
pitch his strong reelect pitches the
economy is really good people are very
positive about the economy right now
they're not in the midst of any serious
foreign crisis he's got a really placid
lake of politics in front of him and the
economy is booming right now and this
should be a great time for him it's no
wonder he's upset because again he is a
chaotic personality in and of his own
right and now Democrats are exacerbating
that by creating a feeling of chaos that
is not really justified by the fact
pattern in front of them at this point
so President Trump is out there
campaigning and he is doing what he does
and president Trump is a stand-up
comedian and out there on the campaign
trail he basically does a stand-up
routine here's President Trump last
night speaking in front of big crowd and
asking whether his slogan in 2020 is in
Pennsylvania whether his slogan in 2020
should be make America great again or
keep America great so now we go ready
Keep America great
ready make America great again whoa Wow
well I like it because they'll sell many
many more hats that way he's a funny
dude and again the fact that he is that
he actually has a strong economic record
to run on means that if there is any
feeling of solidity with Trump if people
feel that Trump is a solid character or
at the very least that he's not going to
bother them too much that he's not in
the eye every moment making them nuts
then he is likely to do fine and his
reelect effort so Democrats now have to
create a feeling of chaos around Trump
now Trump doesn't help himself here as
we'll see in a second he doesn't help
himself
by constantly getting himself into
trouble and saying dumb things but
Democrats with the investigations are
trying to generate controversy around
Trump that is beyond what the facts
support at this point okay we're gonna
get to more of that in just one second
this is where the Biden campaign comes
in we're gonna get to the Biden campaign
we're also going to get to Tim Cook of
Apple apologizing on behalf of baby
boomers but for all the wrong reasons
I'll get to that in just a second first
head on over to Daly we're calm and
subscribe first let me remind you okay
gang our business is growing rapidly and
we are hiring up that means that we are
excited to be offering more
opportunities to become part of our
in-house team if you want to work with
us over at the daily wire head on over
to daily wire comm slash careers and see
if any of our job openings would be
right for you or someone you know and
get your resume ready come work with us
it's really a lot of fun to work here I
mean my employees will testify to it and
if they don't I fired them so it's great
head on over to daily wire comm slash
careers and maybe you'll end up working
here you never know also go subscribe
over daily we're calm right now for
$9.99 a month you can help support us
you can also get the annual subscription
for $99 a year that comes along with
this the very greatest in all beverage
vessels see it believe it the leftist
years Hydra called tumblr woohoo
just incredible feel the power flow
through you as you hold it 99 dollars a
year which is cheaper than the monthly
subscription it gets you all sorts of
fantastic things including access to two
more hours of the show every day I know
we are working hard for your money also
you get the Sunday special on Saturday
we have a great Sunday special this
weekend we'll announce it a little bit
later
this week but you get it on Saturday if
you're a subscriber plus material behind
the paywall
all sorts of goodies coming to you when
you subscribe
it makes a great Father's Day gift by
the way so go check that out right now
also subscribe at YouTube and iTunes
that really does help us we appreciate
it we are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so President Trump on the
campaign trail in Pennsylvania the polls
in Pennsylvania are not fantastic for
President Trump if you take a look at
the polls right now he is basically
losing to Joe Biden that's that's the
person he has to worry about most and
because of that because of that he is
targeting Joe Biden and again I think he
has a fairly solid case against Biden
he's by the way in the polls he's just
getting clobbered right now against
Biden and they're not that many pulls
out right now but the last poll from
Quinnipiac which came out on May 15th so
just a little about a week ago
Biden was leading him 53 to 42 which is
a blowout in favor of Joe Biden Annette
is trouble for president Trump obviously
president Trump needs to win one of the
following three states and maintain all
of the other states as well he needs to
win Wisconsin or Michigan or
Pennsylvania ray needs to win one of
those three states or he loses the
presidency right now if you look at
Michigan 2020 Biden versus Trump you see
that President Trump is not polling
great against Biden in that state either
right now the Emerson poll which is from
March but I assume it actually be more
in Biden's favor now because Biden is
actually jumped in since then had Biden
up 54 to 46 on Trump in Michigan and if
you look at the Wisconsin 2020 polls the
story is somewhat similar Biden versus
Trump in Wisconsin is the the polls show
that Biden is beating him by something
like 8 from that same Emerson poll so
none of this is really positive for
Trump he's gonna have to tear Biden down
well talk in one second about how he can
do that
the chief way that he's going to do that
is by pointing out that his record is
better than Barack Obama's and Joe
Biden's here is Trump saying Obama and
Biden they did a bad job I'm doing a
better job the previous administration
what they did to our country they should
be ashamed of themselves
[Applause]
sleepy Joe said that he's running to
quote save the world well he was he's
gonna save every country but ours what
they've done to us is indescribable
economically we have rebuilt China
they've done a great job and I don't
blame China
I don't blame President Xi I don't blame
them look we allowed it to happen
our leaders allowed it to happen hey so
Trump is gonna be running against Obama
Biden and what he has to do is come up
with some material that damages Joe
Biden the problem for him is that Joe
Biden has a hundred percent name
recognition he was vice president for
eight years and a lot of the dirt about
him is already out there in public view
and some of the dirt doesn't actually
hurt him so Biden right now is winning a
disproportionate share of the black vote
it's the reason why he's clobbering
Kamala Harris and Cory Booker it's also
the reason why if you're Joe Biden the
person you're looking at for a VP
candidate right now
is not Kamala Harris or Cory Booker it's
probably people who to judge you need
young Millennials showing up to vote for
you and Biden figures if I'm clobbering
Kamala Harris with black voters what do
I need Kamala Harris for she's not gonna
drive out black voters I'm killing her
in my own primary there's no reason for
me to pick Camilla Harris so there's
been a lot of talk about what sort of
dirt Trump could throw at Joe Biden and
they've talked about the plagiarism
stuff or maybe his stance on criminal
justice reform I don't think so I think
that the only piece of damaging
information that would really hurt Joe
Biden at this point is if there was
something to the corruption allegations
being made about hunter Biden his son
who was receiving lucrative contracts in
countries in which Joe Biden was doing
business as vice presidents of the
United States that would hurt Joe Biden
attacks that are not gonna fly our ones
like this here's President Trump saying
that Joe Biden left Pennsylvania for
another state note Joe Biden left
Pennsylvania when I believe he was 11
years old
and don't forget Biden deserted you he's
dead from Pennsylvania I guess he was
born here but he left you folks he left
you for another state remember that
please I meant to say that this guy
talks about I know Scranton I know that
well I know the place is better he left
you for another state and he didn't take
care of you because he didn't take care
of you
he led other countries come in and rip
off America that doesn't happen anymore
again that line of attack is that he did
a bad job as vice president's is a much
more telling line of attack than that he
left Pennsylvania when he was 10 or 11
years old nonetheless the the purpose of
the investigations that we are seeing
right now are to create a feeling of
disquiet around President Trump a
feeling that he exacerbates by being the
man that he is and that means that Biden
is doing exactly what I suggested he was
gonna be doing I've I've been suggesting
this for years the Biden would be a
strong candidate against Trump I I
doubted he could get through the
primaries unscathed the way that he has
so far but when it came to a general
I've always said the Biden was a much
more dangerous candidate for Trump than
anybody else mainly because he could run
a 1920 Warren G Harding's style return
to normalcy campaign he could say Trump
is out of the box this guy's crazy
look at him he says wild stuff all the
time and Here I am
Uncle Joe you know me I'm not crazy and
if I am crazy it's the kind of crazy
you're used to and then that's the feel
that you are getting from Democrats who
are basically voting for him because
they think that he is electable they're
voting for him because he is captain
electability as opposed to some of the
other wilds or Democratic candidates the
Bernie Sanders and the Elizabeth
Warren's this is the case that Chris
Matthews everybody say he's trying to
make he says everybody's ribbon jumped
Biden why everybody Joe Biden I come out
here I come out of a show run hero drunk
looking and then I talked to like jump
Biden he's trying to rescue us he's
trying to save us Joe Biden if I were
drowning in a river but dog was drowning
in the river I think Joe Biden would
save me not the dog he's a good guy Joe
Biden go Biden is basically running for
America against Trump he's trying to
rescue us from Trump ISM and Trump
himself
it was very proud I don't know how to go
all the way through to Milwaukee at the
convention I don't know I decided to say
you know it's 50/50 all this
there's always a frontrunner always a
main challenger but his emotion is
patriotic it's not anger
unfortunately for him a lot of the
Democratic Party is about anger right
now anger against corporations against
fossil fuel this is the Bernie yesterday
Sanders yesterday on Meet the Press it
was all anger he was angry at ed Rendell
he was angry at everybody but I think
White's gonna have to grab that anger
and turn it against Trump okay so yeah
that's what's gonna happen he's gonna
run is a solid unifying candidate who
hates Trump's guts that's gonna be great
just do it Chris mattis go yeah Chris
Matthews okay so the the the benefit for
Biden and this is the the narrative
that's being built is that Trump is
volatile and Biden is solid the problem
for Democrats is that many Democrats as
Matthew says correctly many Democrats
don't believe that Biden is going to
punch Trump hard enough so okay well
take an example actor Jeff Daniels who I
don't know why he's on TV talking about
politics I'm just confused like the fact
that he was on newsroom and read lines
written for him by the wildly overrated
Aaron Sorkin here's my rip on Aaron
Sorkin every character that Aaron Sorkin
writes is Aaron Sorkin so when it's a
woman speaking and Aaron Sorkin line
it's Aaron Sorkin wearing the wig and
when it's a black guy reading in Aaron
Sorkin line it's Aaron Sorkin just
played by a black guy like everyone that
Aaron Sorkin writes he does not know how
to distinguish characters but that's
that's an artistic critique not really a
material critique Jeff Daniels I don't
know what his his political expertise
other than that he played a guy on TV he
literally his cases I played a guy on TV
it's pretty amazing here was on on MSNBC
however play why is he there because
he's playing Atticus Finch I guess in
some Broadway production of To Kill a
Mockingbird which Wow I do that does
confer expertise I've also read To Kill
a Mockingbird when I was eight so thank
you thank you Jeff Daniels here's Jeff
Daniels explaining though and then this
this does say something about where the
Democratic Party is he says his great
fear is that Biden can't punch anyone if
politics you know more than I is a
hundred and eighty degrees swing I think
that's part of the eight years of Obama
let's go for the whitest guy we can I
mean I think there's an element out
there in the middle of the country
the other thing what's it ones question
who you watch it Oh Intel it so to go
away from the toddler in chief let's go
to Kamala Harris
let's go somebody with a brain in their
head let's go with someone with some
intelligence who doesn't tweet all day
me repeat I'm looking at intelligence
now is I love Joe Biden is he the guy
that can stand up and punch him in the
face and win
that's for you guys to decide okay Jeff
Daniels's take on intelligence is
definitely worth worth my time I think
but the this is the conflict inside the
Democratic Party is Biden the guy who
can who can punch Trump and and take
Trump down I think what Democrats are
failing to recognize is that the guy who
can placidly take a punch from Trump is
the guy who's likely to win it's not the
guy who's likely to punch Trump it's the
guy who can take a punch from Trump and
emerge unscathed this is why mayor Pete
is actually threatening to trump when
Trump him with the Alfred E Newman thing
which is a great characterization by the
way just on a humor level it is grade-a
characterization but when mayor Pete
says that seems like an old person thing
and then you just sort of lets it go
that is a smart take by P Buddha judge
when Biden acts unflattering was able to
do really well in he's got a gift for it
was he was able to get under the skin of
everyone who ran against in 2016 and
part of that is because Trump speaks
like Trump meaning that a lot of
intellectual elitists run for office
those are people with Ivy League degrees
who are fond of the way that they
command the language president Trump's
command of the language is not
spectacular he is basically a stand-up
comic who doesn't read books and his
popularity is baffling to a lot of
people who got A's straight A's when
they were in high school and it gets
under their skin that Trump is more
popular than they are in a lot of ways
you saw that in 2016 Hillary Clinton was
like listen I've been achieving from the
time I was seven years old and here's
this doofus who grew up on daddy's money
or strolling in the front door and
beating me how is this even possible
hey that's what that was that famous
clip from Hillary in 2016 where she said
I should be beating this guy by 20 how
is this not okay so whichever Democrat
does not have that level of arrogance
whichever Democrats like yeah he's
popular and he's gonna say a bunch of
crap but in the end you know doesn't
have any impact that person is probably
gonna do best against Trump that's not
what the base wants what the base of the
Democratic Party wants is somebody who
punches and you're starting to see
disquiet build in the in the
intelligentsia about Joe Biden
specifically because Trump doesn't seem
to get under Biden's skin in the same
way that he gets under the inteligencia
skin what's really fascinating about
modern politics is that the people who
are the most woke the people who are the
most militant the people who are the
most of
noxious politically speaking are not the
people in the middle of the country it's
not the unwashed masses the people who
are the most obnoxious and woke and
bothersome are the elite who write for
the New York Times the elitists who
write for the New York Times people like
Jamelle Bouie so Jamelle Bouie has a
column today about Joe Biden and it's
sorry it says rather this is Michelle
Goldberg another New York Times elitist
she has a piece in The New Times called
I don't want an exciting President Joe
Biden makes his supporters feel safe but
nominating him is risky why is it risky
to nominate Joe Biden she says what
worries me about Biden is that in
contemporary politics the quest to finds
an electable candidate hasn't resulted
in candidates that actually win voters
don't do themselves any favors when they
try to think like pundits this of course
is simply not true the fact is that many
of the Democrats were elected on a
congressional level ran as moderates in
2018 they were not the hard left AOC
types a oc1 and a deep-blue district by
winning 16,000 votes in a primary
against another deep blue guy Michelle
Goldberg however says that basically
Democrats should vote with their heart
and their heart should say anger anger
not solidity not stability rage and this
is Trump's best prospect Trump's best
prospect is that the Democrats shoot
themselves in the foot hear that they've
crafted this entire world beating
narrative about president Trump the
chaotic man the man of absolute sure
confusion and into the phrase steps a
solid rock of a human Joe Biden I don't
know how that happened but sure and
that's the and then Democrats destroy
that narrative by saying you know what
can I'm Joe Biden would rather have a
chaotic figure like Bernie Sanders or
Connell Harris or Elizabeth Warren step
into that fray that is it that is
Trump's best prospect at reelection
according to Michelle Goldberg and she
says Democrats are now in a complicated
spot as they make their electoral
calculations if what you care about most
is a candidate's chances next November
pretending otherwise is an artificial
exercise particularly if it's just in
the service of making a better judgment
about electability some enthusiasm for
Biden is genuine if not passionate often
when people I spoke to at the rally
described him as safe they meant both as
a candidate and as a potential leader
fair enough for many voters what Biden
is promising a rebuke of Trump and a
return to normalcy is what they want
more than anything else and it makes
sense for them to back him what's
counterproductive is when voters try to
think past their own
desires Goldberg says intensity the
thing that turns a campaign into a
movement matters that's especially true
in a country as polarized as ours or
turnout is as important as persuasion
man I hope that Michelle Goldberg
somehow convinces her party that she is
right that's what I hope is that
Michelle Goldberg and that wing of the
party decide to destroy the narrative
that is being built brick by brick by
the Democrats in Congress and by Joe
Biden on the other side in favor of
somebody so woke the Michelle Goldberg
is happy but the rest of America is
alienated time for some things I like
and then some things that I hate so time
for the thing that I like today so
there's a great book with basically all
of Justices Justice Scalia's writing
Justice Scalia of course one of the
great writers in the history of the
Supreme Court the they've now taken some
of his writings and they've compiled
them along with essays from other people
about Scalia's thinking into a little
booklet called on faith lessons from an
American believer the forward is by
Justice Justice Thomas is edited by
Christopher Scalia and Edward ed Whelan
at the over at one of the foundations
whose name escapes me right now the book
is really great for people who are of
faith it's a great reminder of why you
believe certain things Scully it's
reminder that Scalia was not just a
great thinker that he was a good man who
tried to live a virtuous life and an
intellectually rich life as well and
it's also a reminder that the sort of
scorn that so many people in the
Intelligencia have for people of faith
is totally unjustified if you truly
believe you're living in New York or LA
or something and you truly believe that
you are a higher IQ person than Justice
Scalia or a better thinker than Justice
Scalia because Justice Scalia was one of
these rubes who believes in the whole
Jesus thing read the book and I
challenge you to think beyond your own
boundaries by the way I always encourage
people who are out of faith to read
atheist books and think beyond their
boundaries as well but I've never really
run into religious people who are averse
to listening to thinkers on the other
side it's very rare to find somebody
who's who's an atheist a militant
atheist who's willing to at least hear
the argument on the other side it's why
I treasure my friendships with people
like Michael Shermer who is an atheist
or very least an agnostic who is who's
interested in having those conversations
and any case go check out on faith
by Antonin Scalia it really is a great
book it's it's only a couple hundred
pages pretty quick read okay time for
some things that I hate okay things that
I hate today
so aoc and and her fellow Democrats are
constantly complaining that we don't
want them to be able to speak this is so
confusing
has anybody on the right tried to
silence a OC or l-head Omar likereally
tried to silence them not that I'm aware
of in fact every time they say something
we sort of trumpet it because what they
say is so in unerringly silly so AOC
though claims that the opposition is
afraid when she speaks if that were the
case she would not be a very famous
person right now that lack of fear of
fellowship is exactly what the
opposition does fear that and anytime
Rashida or Ilhan speak they're scared to
myself included and you know it is great
that they got more than they bargained
for well yeah that's exactly what
happened we're so scared when AOC speaks
I'm particularly scared when she starts
talking about vegetables here is a OC
yesterday she must be silenced we must
silence her this is deeply frightening
stuff here is a OC explaining why
cauliflower is a colonialist vegetable
I'm not kidding it's a thing she said as
a human it's too hard to do a green
space that grows you got instead of I
don't know cauliflower or something it
you're what you're doing is that you're
taking a colonial approach
environmentalism it's I went to a
predominantly white community and said
okay you guys are gonna be growing
plantains and you've got and all these
things that you don't know how to cook
it's and that your palate isn't
accustomed to it's gonna be like cute
for a little bit but it's not easy
um yeah I'm scared and we need to
silence her because she's talking about
plantains
well what I'm confused so so apparently
there's a group of in are there really a
group of environmentalists who go around
telling Latinos that
they should not be they should not be
planting yuca is this a thing apparently
this is a thing that happens like down
in the Bronx this is a thing people just
walk around door-to-door and like are
you planting yuca in that in that window
garden so is that is that what you're
doing right there is that yuca
cauliflower kale do it also um
cauliflower is delicious and you could
taste bad um no I'm okay maybe that's
just my my different cultural
sensibility speaking to me here but I
also I don't care if you grow you co who
again who are these people
colonialist vegetables man I'm gonna say
that these are first world problems that
would be a first world problem right
there is a somebody came today they came
to my door and they told me you stopped
growing that sweet potato you stopped
growing that yam it's time for you to
grow some asparagus and I was like whoa
slow your roll there slow your roll that
is some cultural appropriation right
there my garden is my own and if I
choose to grow indigenous crops to the
United States well then that's my
business you white people and you tell
you white people in your flips card
cauliflower
alrighty lady okay sure yeah we're
deeply frightened mm-hmm okay meanwhile
the final thing that I hate today so I
did mention Jamelle Bouie
earlier erroneously now I'm going to
mention him non erroneously he has an
incredibly dumb column today in the New
York Times deeply overrated thinker
Jamelle Bouie
he has a piece in the New York Times
called anti-abortion and pro Trump are
two sides of the same coin both seek to
reinforce and re-establish hierarchies
that were beginning to lose force I am
so bored
with the argument that every time I
disagree with you politically it's
because I'm trying to reinforce a power
hierarchy not everything is power
hierarchies I understand according to
Marxist and and post Marxist thought
that power hierarchies are everything
and either its economic hierarchies or
its hierarchies of race or hierarchies
of sex I understand your
deconstructionist crap about how ideas
about the protection of human life are
secretly in a various ways to control
women's bodies woo I'm familiar with the
nonsensical motives that you put on
pro-life people but it is so sneering
and dumb that it is hard to overstate
how sneering and dumb it is so Jamelle
Bouie his piece today says
all of the measures all these
anti-abortion measures as well as the
heartbeat bill signed in April by
Governor Mike DeWine of Ohio are
designed to bring fetal personhood to
the Supreme Court and then he talks
about in 2016 anti-abortion
conservatives and white evangelicals in
particular supported Donald Trump on the
expectation that he would nominate
anti-abortion judges to the Supreme
Court well partially yes I mean they
expected that he would nominate judges
to the Supreme Court who had not read
abortion into the Constitution of the
United States which is both a legal and
moral absurdity Boyd says the story of
that support which is also the story of
these new laws isn't purely
transactional it's about shared
commitment to the same overarching goal
now everybody on the right is going
right the same overarching goal would be
to stop the killing of the unborn no
wrong you are
according to Jamelle Bouie if you vote
for pro-life laws it's because you hate
women and seek to keep them under your
thumb take that patriarchy he says the
animating impulse of trumps campaign was
defense of traditional hierarchies so
boring it's so boring honestly makes the
conversation boring because I say here's
my pro-life position and here's why I
believe in you say that's not really why
you believe it I'm like well no that is
I just I just expressed you exactly why
I believe it like nope nope that's not
why you believe that you believe it cuz
you're nefarious you believe because
you're evil you believe it because you
hate women I can't have a conversation
with you along those lines once you
start saying that what I believe and my
articulated stance on that belief system
is not actually my real stance my real
stance is a secret hid layering and
motivation to keep women down or
something
then I don't we can't have a
conversation at that point you've
launched a character attack on me if I
say I'm pro-life because I believe in
biology and I believe in the inherent
value of human life and you say no you
just want to take us back to the dark
ages I got nothing for you there's no
conversation that can be had this is the
kind of argument from Bowie that is
meant to quell conversation not to have
conversation he says Trump promised
explicitly to weaken America's
commitment to principles of fairness and
equality to strengthen privileges of
race gender and wealth did he promise
explicitly to do that weird I don't
remember it from saying that Trump
promised explicitly to weaken our
principles of fairness and equality did
Trump say you know what fairness and
equality are bad
I want racial hierarchies to be
re-established
see explicitly is a word that has a
meaning in which it mean it means that
it's explicit like you say it his
personal life says Jamelle Bouie
was defined by its hedonism excess and
contempt for conservative morality but
he pitched himself as a bulwark against
cultural and demographic change a symbol
of white patriarchal manhood aligned
against immigrants feminists and racial
minorities a bulwark against cultural
and demographic change despite his
stated tolerance for same-sex marriage
again now the idea is that even though
Trump was Pro gay marriage that that
wasn't enough his secret motivation was
he wants more white people and fewer
non-white people which would also not
explain why he would be pro-life when a
disproportionate number of abortions are
of minority people in the United States
so none of this makes any sense
but according to Jamelle Bouie it's the
same thing for pro-lifers he says the
underlying dynamic is straightforward
explains Robert P Jones chief executive
of the Public Religion Research
Institute in his book the end of white
Christian America Trump's promised to
restore a mythical past golden age where
factory jobs paid the bills and white
Protestant churches were the dominant
cultural hubs powerfully tapped
evangelical anxieties about an uncertain
future
there's no restoring that past but with
his nomination of conservative judges
and Mitch McConnell successful drive to
confirm them in the Senate
Trump has given white evangelicals and
their Republican representatives the
opportunity to pass the laws and
measures that reflect their ultra ultra
traditionalist ideals so even if from
distances himself from any particular
law that's how one should understand the
new wave of abortion restrictions as
direct attacks on the social and
economic autonomy of people who can
become pregnant to spend pregnant
designed to strengthen strict
hierarchies of gender and then he's and
then he just tells an open lie this is
an open lie in the New York Times he
says the Georgia law would open a woman
to criminal prosecution and jail time
including life imprisonment if she ended
pregnancy after the first six weeks this
is an absolute lie he's just telling
lies now is not true we spoke on our
radio show yesterday with the architect
of the Georgia bill this is 8 it is an
open lie now being repeated into the
pages of the New York Times to make the
case that the real reason that these
evil evil Pro lifers want to say babies
and disproportionately black babies by
the way but the real reason these Pro
lifers want to do that is because they
want to see what a white supremacist
hierarchy where there are more black
people
and brown people in the United States
being born none of this makes sense but
again it is I will say this Jamelle
Bouie is badly motivated he's a badly
motivated guy you're a badly motivated
person if your immediate response to
somebody explaining their theory of why
laws should be the way that it is is
that no that's that's actually not that
are their real their real motivation the
real motivation is obviously something
nefarious and evil you can't have a
conversation with somebody like this
already so we'll be back here a little
bit later today with two additional
hours of coverage otherwise we'll see
you here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam Tsai
Yvette's audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua ov era
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know if it
weren't for the fact that the Democrats
owned the news and entertainment media
it would be obvious by now that they are
living in a blithering fantasy world
Donald Trump is a racist except whose
erases - he's a dictator except what
does he dictates all US but what laws
has he broken they have invented a
Donald Trump of the imagination and he
ain't the real Donald Trump at all we'll
talk about it on the Andrew Klavan show
I'm Andrew Clavin